Enough talk,
let's see this app in action.
I'll open up the Pirate Fleet Xcode
project, and then I'll launch the app.
And as soon as the game launches,
we begin in the guessing phase,
as opposed to when we actually
get to place our ships and
our mines, and
that's something you'll do in code.
Now we've kept the UI pretty simple.
Here at the top we have the opponent's
grid, and at the bottom we have
our grid with our ships and
our mines that have already been placed.
Now as I start guessing, I want you
to think about what objects and
relationships may exist
between the scenes.
So I'm going to start guessing and
I have a little strategy in mind.
I'll try to guess every two spaces
because I feel like that will give me
a pretty good shot at hitting a ship,
being that the smallest ship's size two.
So I hit a mine.
Hopefully I won't fall
too far behind here.
Got one ship.
And it looks like they're doing some
work on my big ships right now.
Yes, here we go.
All right,
I got the two big ships out of the way.
There we go.
Uh-oh, I think they might
all be lined up here.
So if I have enough time,
I may be able to get all of them.
There we go!